bye
we're really excited to envolve launch
the early access program we've always
had an open development process we would
like to talk to the fans about what
features they like and what we can
change and how we can improve things so
this seemed like the perfect opportunity
for us to with Rome I know personally
I'm a fan of a lot of early access games
as a developer it's really interesting
to see how other people feel about the
development process on the inside and to
see that unitive process it's a little
bit too easy to get tunnel vision when
you're developing too many games are
really developed in isolation you're
kind of in this bubble and you don't
really you're too close to the work you
don't really see what's going into it
this allows us to get more exposure and
when you've got all that criticism from
the outside world it really helps you
make the game the best it can be
we're going to start out just releasing
the first two chapters this is going to
cover when Cesar first arrives in Gaul
and he's having trouble with some gulls
who are broad and curious territories
but there will be two more chapters upon
the full release as well as a sandbox
mode which should be really fun and
where you can play as every faction
available in the map you can conquer
Germany as the britons or northern Italy
as the Gauls
as a final note I just wanted to say and
we all here alone but want to say thank
you so much for your support especially
in the early access we really feel like
this will help us make a really great
game and having the community behind us
and involved in this segment of the game
is really exciting and hopefully we can
bring you exactly what you're looking
for so let us know what you think on the
forums join in the community and we look
forward to discussing the game with you
be harsh because it's really going to be
a better game if you tell us exactly how
you feel tell us what's fun and tell us
what's not fun tell us where you got
stuck or where it was too easy